[Music]
hey everybody welcome to the podcast
I've got a great show for you guys today
the amazing Danica Patrick stops by the
studio Danica is a racecar driver she is
one of the most extraordinary athletes
in the world one of the most widely
recognized athletes all across the globe
and somebody who has made a habit of
breaking through the glass ceiling
throughout the course of her career she
was the first woman to lead the Indy 500
race she is the first woman to actually
win in IndyCar circuit race and the
first woman to ever win a pole position
in a NASCAR race so today we're gonna
unpack her career we're gonna talk about
her impending retirement we're gonna
talk about what she has learned over the
course of her journey that is applicable
in your own life and we're gonna talk
about this next chapter in her life so
excited about this one
hope you guys enjoy it of course I'm
interested in your thoughts so please
leave a comment below let me know what
you thought hit that subscribe button
and without further ado please enjoy my
conversation with the great Danica
Patrick alright let's do this Danica
thanks so much for uh for coming out
sure thank you it's like to talk to you
you can turn that you should know it's
not our time we're definitely gonna go
longer than that I hope I hope I don't
run out of things to ask you like a
five-minute clock and I hope you're not
talked out you just came from Rogan
right I did yeah no three hours with him
not quite no we went over two hours but
we didn't get to three I hope you're not
too tired to tell your story once again
no it's never it's never a problem
talking about things that I'm interested
in well cool well I'm just like to talk
to you I know very little about racing
but I have had a couple race car drivers
in here before have you I had well I'm
good friends with Landon Cassill okay
Wow he's really nice such a nice guy
yeah and Leilani Munter okay yeah I know
- no you do so we can unpack a little
bit of that but let's talk about the new
chapter I mean it's been an interesting
year for you you're in transition from
one world to the next yeah I've got a
little bit left in my sort of racing
world just doing two races this year to
finish off my career and that'll be in
the dairy about well it's called the
Danika double because for those who
don't follow racing the double is known
as doing the Indy 500 on Memorial Day
weekend on Sunday and then going
straight the same day to go race the
coke 600 in Charlotte so 1,100 miles of
racing in one day that's known as the
double to different cars to different
cars different states different series
yeah so that would be the double but
this is the Danika double because well
it's just different it's the way I would
do it and it's the two biggest races of
both series and since I've spent you
know half of my professional career in
IndyCar and half of it in NASCAR it's
the Daytona 500 next month which is the
biggest NASCAR race the year and then
finishing up with Andy 500 which is what
I started off in IndyCar racing and so
it's the biggest race of their season so
that's why we call it the Danica double
yeah well you've it's been a long time
since you've been in an IndyCar right
yes it has it's been since 2011 and you
have the sponsors lined up for that and
the cars and everything like that we
hope to be announcing all that stuff
really soon that's cool that's awesome
yeah that's really cool I mean the idea
of going from you know one kind of
racing and car into a completely
different one especially one you know
you haven't you haven't done in a while
that's got a funny daunting and what's
weird and interesting about what you do
your sport is that you can't do it every
day
like if you're a runner you go out and
run every day if you're so yes you ride
a bike every you can't get out on the
track and race a car every day I mean
yeah it's for one it's very expensive
even if you did its tires and engines
and fuel and all kinds of stuff brakes
and whatever else you wear out pounding
around so yeah it's not it's just
totally different it's more of a well I
suppose with like I'd say if you were a
runner or something you could do
everyday
it's really just all you but with racing
its you yes but it's also the build of
the car so really no there isn't many
days that go by that something is not
there's not an effort being put towards
the program it's just not on track
always and obviously it takes you know
teams and teams of people to support a
driver like yourself how involved are
you in like the actual gearhead aspect
do you get into that not at all and in
fact I am I disappointed Joe very much
car driver I'm like well I just not I
don't know I just don't care I I said
that um you know drive cars or like
purses to me I just need one nice one at
a time and when it wears out I get a new
one mm-hmm and you never went under the
hood that much but your dad your dad was
kind of a I don't and erasing and you
know loves that stuff it's more his
passion uh-huh you're just like let me
drive Yeah right
so what is the training like for these
kinds of races um I mean you don't
really I mean how sad is it you don't
really have to be that fit I mean there
are some drivers and both sports but
especially NASCAR that you look at
you're like they don't really work out
that much do you I mean what changing
not really but you have I mean Landon's
you know triathlete guys are getting
into cycling Dale Junior's own interest
mm-hmm
I mean Dale still in Dale Junior's
interested in it was this last year and
he's not racing anymore really so and I
think he's out and does that and Jimmy
does it because he likes it and but you
don't think that has any impact on sure
you know it's physical fitness is
important but you know then you've got
guys like you know Tony Stewart or Ryan
Newman that don't work out and they do
just fine so so I don't think you really
have to so but it is an endurance event
I mean I think I've heard you say like
it's sort of like running a marathon we
have an elevated heart rate for a very
long period time you need a certain
amount of stamina you got to be able to
maintain your focus like incredibly yes
oh right absolutely I think the focus
comes from practice but the but the
stamina you know hydration is critical
so so that's that's something to think
about another than hydration and you
know repetition with the muscles so you
know a general amount of a little bit of
flexibility and some endurance so but
you know there's also like the whole
being race fit which is just basically
being able to you know get in the car
and you kind of get conditioned by doing
it at doing the actual job itself so I
am more fit than I need to be to do the
job yeah but is that oh is that always
been the case because you know now
pretty intense is out your new book
which is great congratulations and you
know it's all about wellness fitness you
have a fitness regimen in there is this
something that you have practiced over
the years to become a better driver or
is this a newer the regimen for you no
it's it's not to become a better drug
it's not really about driving it's
really about being the best version of
myself but but in the context of driving
has that fitness regimen made you a
better driver do you think or is that
relationship not that direct I think the
only thing that I would put towards
being a better driver is that with the
style of working out that I do with the
intensity level with the competition of
it at times you know I think it makes
you mentally stronger so that mental
strength I believe translates mm-hmm one
thing that is another big part of the
new book is mindset yeah sort of your
mentality I mean book it's called pretty
intense right so you're an intense
individual yeah I presume you know God
gifted with a certain level of intensity
so yeah you know what is that intensity
all about and what is your mind so my
set is really I mean the workout stuff
is where I really get into the level of
intensity and you know using things like
mantras to get past it and techniques to
push harder but but the mind the mental
part of the book which is really it's
really cool that a lot of most everyone
has said that's their favorite part of
the book is the first five chapters on
you know the sort of mind-body
connection and the mental aspect of your
life and gaining strength and confidence
through certain techniques and doing
certain things
activities so I but I really like that
because that's where you're gonna find
your foundation for the rest which is
why it's the first five chapters of the
book because your mind the body follows
the mind so if you can tell it to keep
going if you can teach it that believe
it then it will and so yeah the mind
comes first and everybody's really loved
that part and I I love the fact that
they did because I feel like as as as a
culture we're starting to scratch the
surface on how powerful the mind is and
what it's capable of and I love that
because I believe I was born with a
certain amount of that already and you
know through the job that I have which
is unique and different and you need a
lot of that I've been able to you know
continue that development and so you
know unknowingly really if that makes
sense like just you know we understand
your system II believe in yourself and
everything but to really start to
understand how powerful the mind is this
is more new to me and so I look back and
see how yeah like many but ahead of the
curve a little bit on some of that stuff
yeah I think that there's no question
about it that the body follows the mind
that you know the mind has to be in
order in order for the body to follow
and what's interesting is we're in this
period now where we're finally embracing
that aspects you know the mental game
aspect and and the idea that the mind is
trainable it's almost like a new concept
for a lot of people I know we have
science now to back it up and meditation
and all these things but like it's sort
of self-evident especially if you're an
athlete like you kind of know these
things and you come up with this
understanding but I think for a lot of
people it's a struggle yeah it makes me
think of talking to an anesthesiologist
a couple months back about putting
people to sleep and how amazing it was
that you don't have to numb the body
when you put them to sleep and they're
like yeah we don't we don't really
understand it completely I'm like wow
it's because you're in a different
dimension mentally and like you don't
you is pain even really happening if we
don't put anything towards it well what
does put any thought towards it then
right exactly
I mean essentially your body's still
there you're still operating so
breathing you're just kind of sleep
state why don't you feel anything
and even beyond that the idea that that
you can become more focused you can
become more present you can become more
aware you can train your yourself into a
state of you know positive outlook all
of these things that we now understand
we have agency over as opposed to well
that person just doesn't sunny outlook
or you know he's depressed or he has all
the good luck I have the bad luck mm-hmm
it's about manifesting what you want in
your life and what are the strategies
that you employ you know one of one that
simple one is just really getting out in
nature I think that nature is a really
powerful element for us to ground us and
give us some perspective feel at one yet
be in awe at the same time of everything
it kind of creates a state of
appreciation you know gratitude
gratefulness connection I just I don't
think it's possible to go out in nature
and feel worse mmm it's almost not even
possible to just feel the same you feel
better you feel more positive you feel
happier so that's one of them also this
sort of concept of neuroplasticity and
how your thoughts kind of create
patterns in your mind of and they become
normal for you and so you have to
retrain your brain which is the practice
right that's just the practice it's just
you know correcting first it's
identifying your negative thoughts and
then it's correcting them and then they
eventually become all more positive
overall and so you know retraining your
brain and that chapter is called mind
river essentially trying to say that as
you the river cuts in deeper and deeper
and the more you think about something
the deeper it cuts and the harder it is
to get out of that pattern and so make
sure you're make sure you're thinking
things that are positive and good you
can't have a happy life with negative
thoughts mhm and at a sort of
counterpoint or not counterpoint but
like cousin point to that is this idea
of acting as if right yeah like sort of
you talked about this in the book this
idea of like if you're not feeling up
for it just like trick yourself into the
mindset that you're capable of
yeah sort of carry yourself accordingly
as a way of you know creating that new
neural pathway or like embolden mm-hmm
yeah and because it's quick it's amazing
how quickly you do fall into that new
attitude if you you might start off your
day and again it's just your own
thoughts it's your own you're creating
your own reality so if you tell yourself
like oh it's a crappy day then it will
be but if you maybe you start off with
one of those thoughts and you quickly
correct it and identifying like it's
gonna be a great day and I don't care
how over-the-top you are you be
obnoxious about it like say like man I
just saw a unicorn fly by this is gonna
be wonderful I don't care what you have
to do but you will find yourself being
positive and in a good mood much quicker
than you think I mean honestly it
probably takes I mean you could probably
change your mood in minutes if you
wanted to and do you have a formal
meditation practice yeah well what would
you describe as formal sitting as
opposed to like active meditation like
I'm jogging or I'm walking around like
just literally sitting down and you know
practicing a specific technique I wasn't
sure if you meant like once a day when I
wake up no no there's no pattern to it
as but there is formal meditation
practice as well as moving meditation
practice which would be more of my
nature walks and things like that of
listening to and for some reason for me
music gets me there a little bit better
than than pure silence I would think
that it seems to me that every racecar
driver should meditate you know what I
mean like is you have to stay so present
there's so many hours so one thing I did
when I was younger that I do think there
are a fair amount of drivers that do it
but I think there are lots that don't as
I would do visualization for sure when I
was a young kid in go-karting I would
visualize the perfect lap yeah yeah I
don't know how you can maintain that
level of just intensity for that many
hours well you do you develop that but
then there's also the next level and I
think that every sport you see that come
out of an athlete whether it be the last
ten laps of a race is having to start
from the back because you got a pit road
penalty and you were running really well
and you get
and you kind of you're able to enter the
next level mentally and all the sudden
while you had to start in the back maybe
you were running six then you had to
start last and all of a sudden you find
yourself right back up to top five again
and it didn't take any time at all
you're like wait where'd that come from
you've been stuck right here for the
whole race you know where did that come
from I think as a driver as an athlete
as a person we can achieve the next
level but we can't stay there that's not
a sustained state I don't think that
next level mentality but by all means
probably what we do in the car in
general is next level for a lot of
people but I think you know to the
critical level it there is another level
too right but that idea that that you
know let's say you're you're in the
front or you're in the mix near the
front of the race and then something
happens and suddenly you're in the back
you know somebody with a less well
trained mind could then start looping
negative I blew it it's over like just
forget it you know as opposed to
understanding like there's still hours
left in this race there's plenty that
can be done like keep it together
mentally weak and melt down and others
dig deeper mm-hmm how much of it racing
is mental versus physical no mm-hmm sort
of centage I mean I think as far as I
think mental is probably if we're only
talking about mental physical and we're
not breaking it down in any more
categories than that I would say mental
is probably I would think like 75% of it
mm-hmm
yeah there's mental physical and then
there's like mechanical which most
athletes not to worry about that percent
and then when you get beyond the car and
you break down the race yes so the thing
is like if you don't have a great car
like there's only so much you're gonna
be able to do and I think a lot of
racers are in that position where they
could be amazing drivers but they're
just dealing with equipment that's just
never gonna get them there all right
that's 100 percent yeah and when you
look at your when you reflect back on
your career and in the mental aspect you
know of what contributed to your success
and everything you know that you've
enjoyed as a result of that career like
can you pinpoint it to any one
particular thing I mean intensity yes
but what is that actually and like what
do you think it is that that made you
great or that distinguish you from other
competitors yeah it's the it's the the
mindset of being able to focus
critically as well as dig deeper when
times get tough so I'd say in the
longevity of my career and having the
endurance to get through having no ride
or being put down or being judged or you
know having bad days or whatever it may
be it's the mindset it's the being
positive it's being you know it's uh
it's being strong enough to endure those
things out breaking down and where do
you think that comes wrong yeah that's a
great question what do you think I don't
know I don't know you well enough to
know well it's not really about me it's
about anyone well I think that on some
level you it's a result of your
upbringing its how your parents raised
you
it's your environment growing up and
whatever stimulus you had to you know
sort of weather or overcome to be the
person that you are and it's what is
inherently driving you motivating you to
succeed like whatever is behind that
like I don't know only you know that
mm-hmm yeah I think all those things
things well I wonder how much you're
born with I wonder you know I wonder as
we come into this world I mean how much
does our spirit dictate things are we I
don't know you always were you
competitive as a young kid yeah I know
you start racing when you're wrong yeah
right yeah so from I mean I was
competitive with my sister growing up
the phone would ring and I'd be like all
right well race to the phone three to
one and I just sit there someone does I
don't have to go get it you know things
like that I've been competitive my whole
life so there's a lot already there but
then you know my dad is a driven person
and you know he owns his own business
and he was never let being a girl be
something that was a defining factor on
how well I should do it was just about
being a driver so you know my upbringing
and my value system was good for that
I didn't really even think about being a
girl in racing until I started being
asked about being a girl in racing mmm
yeah it's amazing to hear you say that
though because it seems like such an
obvious thing that would have been front
of mind in the beginning really wasn't
until I was 14 and I started being
noticed for doing really well and being
I was on you know getting on TV shows
and I remember the first thing the first
big thing was it was on ABC sports and
it was there on ABC it was a Sunday
afternoon special and it was called
passion to play making of a champion and
it was an hour-long special and it was
myself Tara Lipinski the figure skater
and Anna Kournikova the tennis player
the three of us and we're all 14 and so
yeah that was a long long time ago and
they came and followed me around at my
high school and went to the track with
me and 20 hours of VHS videotape
interviews and back in the day so yeah
so there was a lot of a lot of footage
back then and then MTV came and shot
something for one of their shows that
was about you know kids doing extreme
things and that was before you went off
to the UK yeah I was 14 I was a freshman
in high school so you had to have some
awareness at that time like the whole
thing here like I could that's when I
started to notice yeah but let's take it
back before that so you're eight years
old you start racing go-karts
[Music]
snowmobiles well actually started off in
motocross and then he did snowmobile
racing and then midgets which is like a
on a dirt track where the cars are
sideways and this is in Illinois all
over I mean the racing where you grew up
oh yeah Northern Illinois right on the
border of Wisconsin actually I was born
in Beloit Wisconsin but we lived in
South Beloit Illinois so we were right
on the state line right and when you're
in that circuit as a young kid there's
race I mean what does that world like
there's like races all over the place
like there's a whole world there right
yeah I mean there's local so I started
off with like one track for a year and
then we started going regional so around
the Midwest and then we started going
you know all over the country and I
raced everywhere from California to New
York Canada Florida so yeah raced all
over the place so you just kept going
further and further
and then obviously winning having some
yes s which leads to this decision to
drop out of high school and go to
Britain right I did I I went a lot and
growing up and then it was about what do
you do next
mm-hmm and I didn't want to become a
professional go-kart driver so I was
like well let's go race cars then and so
we I went to England when I was 16 I
pulled out of high school my junior year
halfway through and in fact my junior
year I only was there for the first few
weeks in the last few weeks of the
semester because I was in England I'm
racing as well so I I pretty much only
went through my sophomore year but I
officially pulled out of high school
when I was halfway through my junior
year and then I moved to England why
England what was going on there you know
there was way back when I was 14 14 was
oh I wonder what was going on that's 14
a lot was happening but there was um
where my family my we were at the Indy
500 and we were invited to a sweet a
family that had a race team and so there
was a British guy sitting at the bar and
so I I'm 14 at the bar I just realized
that I'm describing the story like that
but I was just so it was daytime so we
just hung out and I was asking questions
about racing in England and you know lo
and behold I must have struck a chord so
two years later when I was 16 this
family they contacted me and said that
they wanted to meet with me and my dad
and talked about going to race in
England and so it was an opportunity and
we took it and so when you're there
there's like instruction there's teams
was the path or like the idea that you
would end up in IndyCar or ultimately
Formula One or was there well and it was
definitely I I had said that if I don't
make it to Formula 1 I will fit I will
have failed right so let's maybe maybe
describe the differences between like
NASCAR Formula One IndyCar all of that
for people that don't know well they're
all the top levels of each of their
sports so Formula One is International
IndyCar is domestic in the States
it's also open wheel just like Formula
One and
there's NASCAR witches stock car racing
so open-wheel literally just means the
wheels are open and exposed so stock
cars or just the wheels are covered so
NASCAR is the top level of that and
IndyCar is the top level open wheel
domestic and then international as top
level as f1 so I'm sure everyone could
argue why theirs is better right well so
you're in you're in the UK Formula One
is what it's all about
yep and like you meant you were like 201
and soccer horse and at some point at
least I read this somewhere like Jackie
Stewart comes into the equation for the
majority I was there was a little bit
that I thought I might race for him he
had a formal three team over there but
that didn't end up happening but yeah I
mean I rode around in a car with Jackie
Stewart and he was driving me around and
yeah I knew I knew him alright
yeah that's correct if I saw him I he
would remember me today yeah we know
each other a few times is that where you
think like you got the crazy skills like
you really learned drive a car or like
what happened over there I mean not from
him specifically but from like being in
the UK and that experience and kind of
learning what that world is all about
well I think that when it comes to your
ability I mean kind of feel like you can
or you can't you see you have it are you
know yeah that's why I think in racing
you see just the driver on their own
it's not like any other sport where
there's a coach for everything you can't
like learn a play and run it or you know
what I mean like runs I mean it's just
it's all instinct it's all so it
happened so fast it's a feel on such a
fine level that you know you just have
to have and yeah I just have to have
that ability for it so you know usually
if someone's good they're always good
always good it seems like there could be
like virtual reality games that could
help improve your driving like you know
how pilots go into the simulator and
learn how to you know learn how to fly a
plane like it seems like there should be
something like that for driving so you
could practice consistently
maybe I'm from a visual standpoint but
you'll never replicate feel so you can't
replicate g-forces lateral load slip of
the tires you just can't replicate that
videogames in my mind simulators because
I've been in a couple simulators are you
mean simulators for people who wanna
play video games
yeah well that goes against the whole
nature thing so yeah so what do you
think it is that that distinguishes like
a good driver for a great the only thing
you can do that will help you develop as
a driver is to put yourself in more
scenarios where you're uncomfortable to
expand your comfort zone so new cars new
environments new conditions different
changes all that stuff factor that I
think is about the only thing you can do
that would really help you develop as a
driver and the dividing line between a
good driver and a great driver is yeah I
think one of them is probably what I was
mentioning earlier about being able to
sort of tap into that that higher level
of consciousness maybe or that much more
Intune elevated state that gets you to a
further along place and on track where
you can focus better drive harder
believe more I think that's one of them
I think if you can get into that space
in that zone more often for longer that
I think that trickles down right so
confidence gets you a lot of places so
you know being able to not only believe
what you're doing on track but then have
that translate to the people working on
the car and you know having them believe
it just as much as you think all those
things are really powerful because then
they're going to give you a better car
and you go faster when your car's better
well kind of like pedestrian driver are
you like when you're just driving crazy
are you I'm I'm good tickets and stuff
yeah the only what happens what a
couples you over the only way I can
guarantee that I'm not gonna get a
speeding ticket as if I don't drive
because I won't
I will speak driving do you drive a fast
car
well I I've had various different cars
over the years I I've had everything
from a Lamborghini to a big mom SUV so
you know i I've run the gamut of all
different kinds of vehicles so and when
a cop pulls you over and sees it sees
its utens I'm hopeful that happened does
it happen has an event happens I usually
get out of the ticket yeah but it's one
day like oh she can't help that you know
I think that if they knew who I was and
they said it I don't think they're not
gonna give me a ticket but I think
sometimes they might know who I am and
they don't say it so they can give me a
ticket
yeah nice that I'm breaking the law do
but you know when I was careful
I can't open I have a large comfort zone
but I think that I should uh I think I
should pull out my FIA racing license I
only have a little bit more time to have
that license since I got one year left
on my schedule here but I'm gonna pull
that out of it when I get pulled over
again I'm sure anybody's gonna speed it
should be me yeah I know what I'm doing
a new car I know that argument probably
won't go over well take it anyway so
screw it
yeah okay try write because what makes
me mad is when I don't try it all and
I'm like she's just as they're walking
back to the crime like I really just
hope that they recognize I Know Who I am
and they put it together and they go you
know what slow down huh huh huh it cuts
both ways though it could be like oh she
thinks she can do that because she's who
she is like I do sorry I'm just being
honest I'm qualified so all right so
you're you're learning your craft in the
UK start racing you come back to the
United States to give me what happens
next well I didn't have a ride I was um
I was over in England and it was towards
the beginning of the season and mm I
think it was and I remember my sister
was over with me and my manager called
and said don't get in the car tomorrow
and I was like oh my god and it was a
race the next day
already been on track practicing
qualifying and I was like this is the
weirdest thing not driving to the track
today and and then I went home and I
didn't have a ride 2000-2001 and then
well the last half of 2000 and the first
half of 2001 finally at the end of 2001
I I got a ride in another series that
car didn't end up racing so it gave me
another chance to look for the real ride
that I wanted and open-wheel racing so
then I found one in 2002 and then I
raced formula Atlantic in three and four
and then IndyCar five six seven eight
nine ten eleven and full-time NASCAR
twelve through now right and you start
you know breaking through all these
boundaries in IndyCar that's some crazy
success like I'm looking at your
Wikipedia's I can't remember all of
these results there's just like way too
many races like how do you even like you
know the big the there were there two
big ones third thirty five hundred and
two thousand five and then 2008 you win
Indy Japan yeah in 2005 actually at Indy
I came off of finishing fourth in Japan
qualifying on the front row is only my
third IndyCar race third and I think
third or fourth only a few and and then
Indy 500 I am oh I have I I get a little
loose and turn one on lap one because I
told myself I wasn't gonna lift and
qualifying it was kind of cold that day
and say hey a little sideways I still
qualified fourth and that was the race
that I was leading really late in the
race and I ended up finishing fourth but
that was quite a breakthrough because
there's a lot of buzz about me being
there and being fast and it really did
almost win the race so 2005 Indy 500
2007 Indy 500 I finished third and then
2008 I wanted Japan and what was that
like that period of time I mean it must
have been crazy right the amount of
attention being thrown five we kind of
nicknamed Danica mania because it just
kept coming like I remember it was
really close to the race to the Indy 500
race and in May and again I had only
been in IndyCar Series for a couple
months and I was so just
over everything interviews and since I
had just started a really rise in
popularity right then everybody kept
asking for interviews new ones every day
and so I remember I told my my PR guy
was like Brent I can't do a single don't
even ask me for one don't just don't
even ask and he was like called and he's
like morning America when I said don't
even ask it and so we ended up doing it
somehow but but I was I had had enough
is it overwhelming yeah well I think
when it comes so fast it is um
you know I could not handle what I'm
doing these days schedule wise five
years ago and ten years ago you're like
24 25 years old when this is going on
right yeah mm-hmm yep so you know it's
all kind of coming quickly
but you know I'm it you get used to it
just like races I mean my races were ten
laps long and they're 20 and then
they're 40 and then they're a hundred
and you know you build up to five hours
in the car and kind of baked into this
is this mantle that then you're come
shouldered with that you're this
empowering female role model you're
breaking these barriers I mean the only
woman to ever win an Indy race right
highest finisher Indy 500 yeah
and to this day or there are there women
in IndyCar now is there any other women
ah not that I know of right now yeah and
what about NASCAR no yeah not at the top
ten years after this still right so how
do you like how were you processing all
of that at that time same way I am now
yeah and what is it like now like how do
you think about your your sort of role
with respect to all of that uh it's
somewhat of a duty um like I was given a
special gift and an ability to do this
and you know I felt like felt I feel
like on some level it's while I am
retiring though it's it's been my duty
to follow through and to keep pushing
and going for not only for myself of
course which is the look if I don't want
to do it I won't do it anymore which
leads me to what I'm going where I'm
going now but
but for the inspirational element to
that's the powerful thing that you don't
really realize when you're doing things
is how it can affect someone else so
that was a pretty cool element to kind
of discover over time and when you're
young you get asked about being a role
model and you're like shoot I need one
like I'm just I'm just starting off but
then you get older and you answer
questions about it which is almost like
therapy because you're like you don't
even know what to say but you've to come
up with something and I just wait for
you to say the inspirational thing yeah
and or how or why like what do you what
would you tell young girls or what's
your advice and how did you get to where
you are now and you know at first and
you get asked that question like I don't
know you just did what you like doing
yeah but then you kind of end up
identifying over time and in in contrast
to other people how maybe your mindset
is different and how it could help
people well I would imagine you have
young girls coming up to you all the
time right who want to connect with you
or just want to tell you how much you've
inspired them and I would imagine that
that sort of you know has to impact you
emotionally on some level yeah it does
yeah it's a definitely a lot of very
grateful um makes you want to do more
yeah you better and yet you know ten
years after these you know the sort of
pinnacle like your biggest successes
there still aren't there's no women and
these that wasn't my goal no I know it
just the trickle-down impact just you
being yeah this huge name in the sort
you would think yeah
by now I mean maybe there are I hope
there are women who are kind of like
coming up again my my goal to inspire
has a lot more to do with people
following they're following their dreams
and but for one having one I mean that's
their that's the start if you don't know
what you want how do you get anywhere
and most people don't even know what
they want
most people don't they don't that's why
they're wasting money going to college
for a general degree because they still
don't
what they want so how do you get
somebody to know what they want well
they have to have to let the ego step
aside and they have to really be true to
themselves instead of what their friends
or culture or high school or their
buddies or someone like that tells them
they're supposed to be like or some guy
tells some girl what she should look
like or do or how she's supposed to act
you have to get to the core of who you
are and it's not as easy as it sounds
and I cuz I think a lot of that comes
from being alone and that's not
something that we do very much of when
were younger we don't really want to be
alone and it's punishment also it's also
harder and harder to be with yourself
now because you're just constantly
destroying your phone it's so hard which
is what practice is so valuable because
like that I always see stuff pop up on
social media about should meditation be
a class in school I'm like yes I mean
you should teach teach kids from a young
age the value of being able to listen to
them listen to the inner voice and be
quiet and well there's truth in the in
the silence and so you know that that
comes to people when they get good at
listening to it but but it you don't
know if you don't ever learn how to be
quiet then how do you ever hear it yeah
I agree completely
we're so socially conditioned to just
get on a certain track and follow that
track and if you step a little bit to
the left or the right of it people get a
little nervous you step outside of it
then they get really nervous and if you
decide to go become a race car driver
then people freak out ya know it's and
so people stay in their Lane and then 20
years later I'm like what am i what am i
doing you know I don't even know and and
if you ask that person what is your goal
or like you know what what makes you you
or like what is your heart song or what
gets you out of bed in the morning most
people don't even know how to answer
that question and it's not their fault
it's because they were reared in a
system and in an environment where that
kind of that line of questioning was
never a priority I disagree with that
somewhat it is their fault they're the
only ones that can change it but I
you feel like they're the only ones that
can change it but if you're from a very
young age being message in a certain way
100 percent made more difficult and some
sometimes you're not you don't have
access to different mentalities
environments but you really are the only
one that can change it so you know so
it's about access it's about raising
awareness about that about your mind
it's about you know so that's why I mean
I've written dream big on a million hero
cards for people because I especially
for kids because I mean it and what's
funny is when I go do like let's say
there's something for like the Girl
Scouts or something and I that is my
message but I also cuz there's parents
in the room as well I'm also like for
kids but adults too because we all can I
mean look at Betty White Betty White's
working and she's like 150 you know like
we you know you can work okay she's like
80 or 90 years yeah exactly so you can't
tell me that you can't have a career
when you're 40 or 50 or 60 I mean you
can take on new projects and no one
wants to just sit at home and do nothing
so you know it's and it's really not too
late to follow a passion sometimes it
might not be able to reach maybe its
pinnacle or highest level based on maybe
your age but you can definitely still do
it and have an effect and find joy in
that and so the challenge for everyone
that I give them is what would you to
answer the question if you could do
anything in the world what would you do
and most people don't have an answer
most children do though most children do
gets beat out of them at some point yeah
well they get put on you know you'd like
you said but like I would I might you
get put on the wheel right you're just
like on the mousewheel and you just keep
going cuz you know you go to school and
you're you know you're your creativity
is dampened by you know reading out of a
book and sitting in a specific chair
raise your hand can I go to the bathroom
you know like it's just you know very
regimented and then you know you you've
got to figure out what you want to do in
life but you've not been given the
mental capacity or creative space to
really actually know what you want to do
and you've been culture eyes by you know
media and social media and TV and all
other things that go on and then you are
like well I don't know what to do but I
got to go to college and now you're in
debt so you get whatever job you can get
because you got to pay the bills now cuz
you're out of college and got your
general degree and then you're doing a
job that you don't like but you have to
do it because if no other option and
you're too scared to try anything new
because you're stuck there you have to
pay your bills and it's just like this
horrible cycle and then you become
resentful yeah resentment devolves into
anger and then you start trolling people
and Twitter social stalking but even
that kid you know back in elementary
school social stalking a trolling
trolling of the means everything yeah
well it's what they're the trolls are
it's more about it's all about them and
their mental state of course I feel such
sympathy and sadness for those people
the trolls did you see what I have I
can't do that like there's no way I'll
be able to tell a stranger especially
like if it was a famous stranger like oh
you're such a piece of whatever I wish
you would have died in that rack or you
know you're such a you don't know me
mm-hmm so it's lucky for me because you
know 99.99% of those people I don't know
but like now sort of shift it to school
and kids and you know somebody says
something mean I'm socially media I mean
like look they've got you know what
thirty eight followers yeah they know
all their fault they know those people
were impactful because they're like wow
you called me fat you know what I look
like you know what I mean like or you
know you you called me me you know shoot
you walk by me in the hallways you know
there's just it's so much closer to home
for kids they can't escape it and social
media is just so dangerous from that
perspective so even myself I find myself
like unfollowing people as I go along to
some degree just because if I'm like if
I have a negative thought enough times
about someone and what they're doing or
saying I have to unfollow me I realize
it's a bad pattern bad mental pattern
it's not productive for me or allowing
that into your space you're making a
decision about what you what you're
consuming yes don't coming into your
boundary yeah and I think being more
mindful about that is important but to
your point about kids it's devastating
you know bullying is bad enough without
the
tools of technology that can amplify you
can hide behind it yeah it's it's it's
really devastating and you know like
kids back to your earlier point like a
kid in elementary school who maybe is a
little bit different because he wants to
draw comic books or become a stand-up
comedian or showing any kind of like
creative flair or interest that's
outside the narrow scope of whatever is
being taught and that's in that
classroom right is rather than
encouraged maligned and and and told
that they're different or there's
something wrong with them right and we
really need systemic structural changes
to identify those kids and to support
them yeah they can really that person
who you know they want to be I've heard
about some schools that are a little bit
more progressive and uniquely different
in their structure I don't know a lot
about them but I've heard a few
different examples but I mean I think
that the school structure is just so
outdated the institution of it is so
outdated definitely did you see what's
how Sarah Silverman dealt with a troll
recently kind of like made news oh no I
thought he was trolling her but I didn't
read it I can't remember what the person
said but it was it was just a bit of
nastiness with a nasty word like the
c-word or something like she did to them
or no no somebody did to her somebody
said to her and she kind of responded to
this person with this unbelievable like
message of compassion like I'm so sorry
you must be a very happy person or yeah
or I can hear your pain and you know
behind that and you know let's talk
about it and she ends up in this
dialogue with this person at the end of
it like this guy is like you're amazing
fighting all this secret and like I'm so
unhappy and this happened to me and not
having to mean she ends up like getting
this person help wherever he lives for
his whether it was depression or he had
back problems or always think it was
like that's bent at this master class
and how to like really flip the switch
on the whole thing find yourself on
Oprah no time well she's amazing so you
watch what is it on Oprah it's Sunday
it's super super soul Sunday I haven't
watched it
oh great kind of gets more yeah so
you've had it but you've had to deal
with heaters and say I wish I would I
would have died in an accident of course
people are so me and rude it's so crazy
well that saying mean things about the
way I look or the way I act or what I do
absolutely but again they're strangers
yeah and what do you think that's about
like you're just just your existence is
threatening to their I like it is a
reflection of what they can't do and
they they are it's their insecurities
screaming out that they can't do it and
just block them or mute them or what is
your strategy times but I've done a lot
less of that I just tend to not look at
it that much to be honest
yeah well to me I might look at the
feedback on Instagram let's say like
maybe some recent ones or maybe I'll
flip back a couple but you know there's
500 responses so I'm not gonna read them
all mm-hmm and I I don't recommend
anyone does right it's an interesting
time right now we're in this you know
moments of incredible female empowerment
with the me to movement and a lot of bad
behavior getting routed out and as you
you as somebody who's you know basically
in you know emblematic like this
ambassador of female empowerment you how
you see do you see yourself as somebody
who needs to speak to that at all or are
you just doing your thing yeah I mean I
I know what you're talking about I don't
find myself in sort of those very public
sort of Hollywood circles of like
awareness on something or getting
involved in movements or whatnot I try
and live my life as an example in and of
itself and stress the importance of
confidence and knowing who you are and
what you want from life I think if it
affected me directly that I would say
whatever the hell I wanted to your
shooter yeah that's my truth but I also
you know depending on what's going on
there's it's hard to know the truth
about anything completely and so you
know I tend to see things that pop up in
the media and I'm like well but you know
what about this and what about that and
really it's a matter of knowing your own
personal space your own personal
confidence your own worth and I'm not
putting yourself into situations that
are risky but then there's a lot of it
where you know humanity in and of itself
you know probably a little bit more men
towards women at times there needs to be
a respect it just has to be I mean we
all need to respect each other more like
those great more like were more alike
than not all of us and you know we need
to embrace that and understand that and
the old you'll think can't we all just
get along yeah I mean why why can't we I
don't know I wish we could maybe we can
help help together we can help get there
I agree I do believe that somewhat of my
role I mean I'm look forward to that in
fact one of my hopes is is that the book
is successful and that especially the
mental part of the book resonates with
people and I've heard great stories
about it just for my own friends and how
like one of my friends his mom will read
the book and I just heard this story the
other night and how she loved it so much
and she was surprised and almost by and
she's like buying it for all of her
girlfriends and but I would love to make
a book for each section of the book the
mind the body and the and the food and
have it but the mental book was what I'd
want to write first because I think
that's what our culture needs the most
what I like about the book and kind of
what preceded it was this intention this
idea of not just writing a book like
here's all my secrets or whatever but
doing like involving your community like
by setting up this website pretty
intense calm and the Facebook group and
like really crowdsourcing you know the
people that are into what you have to
say and do and getting them involved and
taking them on this journey with you
towards whether it's weight loss or
changing their diet or whatever to get
them healthy and and then sharing those
success stories like throughout the book
he's really cool
the focus group test was a great idea
and I loved that I was able to test it
out and so as her I also was sure that
incorporated into the program we did
this a year ago so January through March
of last year 700 people signed up for it
and which they
had to send a before picture in and
every one of them was was screened like
they had to be a qualified before
picture because I didn't want everyone
to just sign up and then be like not
take part or think like why would I buy
the book now I already got the work out
there is so much more to the book than
just the workout so 700 people were in
and there was just such incredible
success stories but my point that I
wanted to make was that it was very
important to me that there was there was
a forum so that I could talk to anyone
that had questions because again I'm new
to this I know what I'm doing but you
know providing structure from a diet
standpoint or a fitness standpoint or
even like a mental standpoint like I
loved being able to be honest with these
people in this new capacity that I was
in this new space because a lot of it
had to do with telling them they just
loved making excuses why they couldn't
stop eating dairy or they couldn't stop
doing this or that and I wanted I just
was able to tell them that their own
their own way and they can do whatever
they want to do kind of thing so but
there was such it just really went so
well and it was fun to engage with them
on that level but a limited level like I
can't I couldn't do a thing all day
people that are buying the book and
doing the program because it's not you
know it's not like a core group of 50
people that keep talking to me on it
it's you know wider than that so I can't
do it now but it was great to do in
developing the program and understanding
more so I could make it better for
everyone else on the book came out in
the book you say kind of point-blank I'm
not gonna bore you with my personal
story yeah you kind of just don't and
you don't like you don't yeah I know and
then it's just all about like here's how
to help yourself
you know hear all these tools etc but at
the same time I was like yeah but your
story's cool like that's not gonna bore
anyone you know what I mean like like
let's hear a little bit about your story
because I think that in that like that's
why people are buying your book because
they want to connect with me you are no
they can't be you but they can they can
learn from your example you know - these
are all the things that I've found make
me a better person and have helped me
and so it's really about finding your
own in
confidence in your own Worth and your
own dreams if you don't then it's all
temporary mm-hmm yeah I guess that's
true no you have to have you have to
have a goal you have to know why you're
doing something you have to have and
even in the program I don't even
recommend that your goal be to lose
weight like I don't even recommend that
be your goal because you will like if
you do the program you will there's no
way around it you're going to you're
gonna lose weight you're gonna feel
better you're gonna have more energy
you're just gonna it's if you do the
program as it's written out you will
what I really hope is that people want
to keep doing it and it becomes a new
way of life and that's why I also say
and I said this and when I wrote the
website for the for the focus group
testing year ago that it will change
your life in ways in and it will
absolutely change your life it's written
on the cover of the book and it will but
in the best of ways I say because it's
gonna change everything it's gonna
change the way you eat the way you
grocery shop what standards are okay for
yourself and within your family for your
friends for your children for for anyone
it's gonna it's gonna change some of
your structure about what is important
for you like you know going out for
drinks or is it going to get a workout
you know what I mean like I mean it's
just there's certain structural things
that will change but it's gonna be all
the bet for the best I mean you're gonna
feel so much better you're gonna be
better for you which one you're better
for you you're better for everyone else
what I found with these kinds of things
just in my own personal experience and
and you know other people that I've
worked with is the goals change because
when you begin if you're not used to
practicing certain lifestyle habits
they're not rote and part of who you are
you set a certain goal but that goal
isn't its most likely like not the right
goal for you because you're so
disconnected from who you are you don't
even know what your own goal is it goes
back to what we were talking about about
if you don't know yourself well enough
to know what it is that you aspire to or
what it is that you want to pursue with
your life then how can you be expected
to set a goal that is in alignment with
that higher sense of self right so but
you said it you achieve it but in the
practice of achieving it you learn
something about yourself that reveals
more to you and then perhaps you set a
different goal or you
like maybe that goal wasn't like goal
for me I do believe that once you
finally if you set goals for yourself
that aren't in alignment with your true
self they just aren't going to happen
very easily and they're going to meet
resistance they're gonna be tough it's
gonna be it's just not going to flow
like things are just not gonna flow with
that with that goal once you do set ones
that are in alignment though all the
sudden things start to click and happen
and synchronicities going left and right
and you're like oh my god and to me
those are like the green flag like
someone waving going doing good keep
coming like you know you're on the right
track but when things are not happening
easily it's about recognizing that maybe
it's not about giving up but
understanding this is not the way and
conceding and understanding that
shifting to a new direction is in fact
just the smart wise thing to do instead
of trying to force something because
things that are meant for you and in
alignment will flow to you easily so
then what are the goals that you have
for yourself now well I'm gonna be
specific like I can I can start just
listing things or you mean for myself
like business-wise well I think it's
interesting that now that you're not you
have these the Danika double coming up
but that aside you're entering this new
phase of your life where it's not just
about getting a certain race result like
you're trying to build this new career
essentially and what's interesting is
that you didn't wait until you were
retired to then figure out like oh what
am I gonna do now like you kind of set
this in motion you know and you've
stepped into this with you know some
grace and success and you have this
amazing social media platform that you
can then leverage to talk about the
things that you're interested in that
you care about so in your mind like
where you know why is this the path that
you've chosen and where do you want to
take it well I will say that as far as
sort of doing things they're in line
with you happen easily I mean I have
wine that's out finally after a long
process because it just is not because
it wasn't a good path but with a great
name somnium which is dream
in Latin that's in Northern California
yeah it is it's in Napa Valley
so that's finally for sale and that's
all flowed really well it's just you
know you can only grow grapes as quickly
so you can get them get the permits and
dig it up and plant the vines and plant
the root stock and all the rest of it
but that's coming through now which is
really great and it really follows in
line with my lifestyle of food and
taking care of yourself and lifestyle
and being present and and so there's the
wine then the clothing line warrior that
like things like like oh maybe as an
example I remember I was trying to do a
perfume like many many years ago and I
couldn't even get a name that worked
like everything's taken it's just not
possible and so it happened I tried to
do it twice and it didn't work out now
like that's just an example one example
now fast-forward to my my my clothing
line
I don't know how warrior was available
but it was and it was like effortless
easy no problem
so I have a clothing line now it's all
flowing very easily you know we got
picked up by HSN to to sell it which is
a great starting platform mm-hmm and
then then the book with pretty intense I
was asked by my agent if I was
interested in writing a health and
fitness book and I was like yeah
actually I think I am I think I finally
have something that I want to say and a
program that's worked better for me than
anything I've ever done so the book came
the the name came easily the you know
workout program I mean I write workouts
for myself every single day so this was
like but this is the real start of it
you know I wrote the whole thing and
writing it with some fluidity and build
for someone who like is working on air
squats and I'm over there doing clean
and jerks I mean that's a pretty big
difference between the two of those
things so you know building that
progression up was really fun and it
just flowed really nicely and it has
impacted lives and such a I'm talking
about like my mom like not just
strangers but my mom even I'm like mom
I'm your daughter I could have done this
for you any day you wanted like I could
have wrote a program for you any day but
so you know just affecting lives and
having that go so well and you know just
off I mean the book has recipes I love
to cook so food and wine taking care of
yourself working out and the mind and
presence and all that stuff it just all
flows really well so you know I would
say that you know on the heels of doing
things that are in alignment I feel like
they've all been very easy to me they've
all come very organically even the
clothing line came as a result of me
going to this company wanting to sell
clothes at the racetrack and because us
as drivers get such a little cut of that
so we we just I was looking for a way to
make money that way while I was still
around and they never made up clothes
for the racetrack they came up with a
whole different whole bigger bigger idea
for me
so all that stuff just came really
easily right so the point being like you
go where the energy is yeah is working
right so the perfume like maybe I
shouldn't be doing this right like you
know driving you know racing beyond last
year full-time it just wasn't happening
so let it go mm-hmm not in the way that
I want to do it anyway yeah I mean it
was you had another year on your
contract
I did but my but this is another thing
too at the beginning of 2017 my primary
sponsor left so that's new to me I've
been fully funded since day one of
everything I've ever done I've always
had support so you know I just was one
of those unique scenarios I had never
been in before that was to me a sign
that maybe it's time to move on did you
feel like you weren't able to leave on
your own terms I think that there was a
little bit of that and I think that's
part of kind of what ended up leading
into how am I going to finish my career
off in a way that is appropriate and
feels good to me so I was okay to be
done but then we were throwing you know
my agent kept throwing around ideas and
I kept saying no you need to be okay
with me being done it's coming relax and
then he asked me last year late fall and
if I wanted to he's like what have you
finished up with the Daytona 500 and I
was like hmm what about the Indy 500 and
I really was only referring to the Indy
500 like just doing that one race and he
was like man he's like it'd be really
cool if you did
and I'm like Oh both that's a good idea
actually that's perfect let's do it and
I got off the phone I called I made a
couple other phone calls and I was like
hi am I crazy that I just agreed to this
they're like no it's effing awesome we
love it
it's a mate I mean it's perfect for
creating like a media frenzy to like
people it's because it's a story it's
super interesting but on that one for
those who have followed this story they
they they probably are recognizing that
it wasn't all done and dusted when I
said it I mean that guy I agreed to this
like maybe October of last year and then
November we made the announcement and I
thought we were close to the team but we
weren't and a sponsor and then you know
we kind of had and here we are in
mid-january and things are still not to
the public although they are very very
closely tonus everywhere yeah it's a
month's less than a month away now
almost so you know it took a lot longer
but it deals were not done I just looked
at everyone and I was like this is
happening it's going to happen and I
like willed it so and and I will say
yeah manifester exactly and so I and I
also have recognized in the process how
there have been things that have just
been difficult and I'm like why is it
difficult and then in the end the way
everything's coming together now I
recognize why it was difficult and it
just all needed certain things needed to
not happen to allow other things to
happen so it could fit in this really
nice space of getting the right support
and waiting long enough to reach out to
certain people about certain things and
it's like oh it makes sense now and so
you know it doesn't mean don't try it
just means don't force something yeah
because if you had on another
circumstance if you had finished out
your contract then the idea of the the
demon could double wouldn't have
occurred you wouldn't have just would
have like sort of been done right it's
interesting that if I feel like as
somebody who doesn't know that much
about racing I feel like you know look
there's there's been a lot of changes in
NASCAR like there advertiser dollars
weren't what they were and ratings seem
to be not what they were and it it seems
like there's more pressure on the
drivers to deliver the sponsors as
opposed to the teams and there's this in
balance in terms of the drivers ability
to kind of control the situation you
know I don't know I'm not saying as much
so they're relying on you to go out
there and win the race so that they get
on TV for it and it's like the way that
we always do our deals is no matter who
it is we try and make sure that the
sponsor wins before I ever get on track
and everything that I do on track and
any attention I get is icing on the cake
mm-hmm but there's no there's no like
driver Union or Association is there the
NASCAR in NASCAR we did there was an
effort to try and kind of create a
little bit of a driver council union
group right but that was a kibosh by a
NASCAR team but that also wasn't that my
understanding is that wasn't generated
by the drivers right that kind of came
down drivers but you know when people
catch wind of it again you know nobody
wants to lose power so our point was to
make it ourselves more powerful as
drivers in the voice and so you know
people find a way to kind of damper that
yeah well there's the superstars at the
top and they don't have a lot of
incentive to get all mucked up by that
sure but there's everybody else who yeah
really benefit from yeah that kind of
people they just want don't want to rock
the boat right how does all the
merchandising stuff work that's terrible
it's absolutely terrible I made some
extra money I made so much more money in
IndyCar merchandise sales in NASCAR like
probably four times so that is the team
take the money or where does that we're
hookahs she got sponsors cut in on the
spot on the dot on the advertising like
oh yeah even sponsors get a chunk of
money budgets Annika Patrick t-shirt
sure yeah cuz it used to flow like the
rivers of Capistrano right it was it was
you know back in the day drivers were
making millions of dollars off their
t-shirt sales and now know that's a big
reason to Hugh knives right there that
doesn't it's just a terrible
infrastructure too many hands in the
cookie jar mm-hmm and do you ever wish
that you had raced Formula one like what
how come you never ended up pursuing
that I don't because what I ended up
realizing after I came back from England
and how
the whole the whole saying of like I
will have failed if I don't make f1 I
realized that succeeding was about being
to be is to be good on track and to be
good on track I need to be in an
environment where I'm happy I realized
that at the end of the time that I was
in England and I realized that I was
happiest when I was home and with not
only my family and friends but creature
comforts of like even just something
simple like breakfast like in England
they don't really do very good breakfast
over there so you know the side of the
road is not really gonna do the trick
and you know sweet onion jelly
you know sandwiches from the roadside or
not are not going to cut it so I'm I'm a
little high-maintenance in that category
so I was just like I just like being
home and I realized I was happier and
when I'm happier I do better so I had to
redefine my levels of what successful
was to me are you still living in
Charlotte no no no you moved I moved you
back to Phoenix back to Phoenix yeah
yeah you've had some some lifestyle
change yeah we don't have to go into
that talked about I mean that's like you
know paparazzi stuff but like you you're
you concluded a long-term relationship
and kind of around the same time that
you're shifting into this new life and
so you know that's a lot
timing is I mean time I was great hmm I
mean if I was still racing I would still
be doing that same exact schedule and I
wouldn't be entering a new space and
happy and you know doing doing these
other new things yeah can we talk about
the migraines oh yeah I got to tell it
when you mentioned not racing as much I
might again I used to get them on Sunday
nights after my race races right so for
Monday and Tuesday they would be
horrible and I probably had a dozen or
so in the last two years that are just
like sometimes sometimes they get to the
point where I have to just close my eyes
and go to sleep sometimes it was like
I'm nauseous and I feel horrible I threw
up once or twice I mean like there Tara
get them
I don't but Julie my wife we met like I
forgot to mention to her that you suffer
from those because she has gone through
like the gamut with this like and she's
determined to get to the other side of
it and she does all kinds of you know
amazing experiments on her okay try that
no just more logical like lifestyle
stuff food or no yeah like she's really
into Ayurveda so like yeah kinds of
Ayurvedic treatments and we got a
Clearlight infrared sauna and she's
doing like hot oil massages in the sauna
and like she's just journaling
everything and I was able to identify
mine mine were number one that came up
really easily was obviously
understanding that it was probably at
some level of dehydration so if I had
you know one or two drinks on a Sunday
night after a race I had a much higher
chance of having a migraine the next day
like didn't take very much so that was
one of them for sure
for another one that's out of my control
is and I found this out later because I
ended up doing a deal with excedrin
migraine because I had them and they
heard about that is coming down so
adrenaline up or adrenaline down can
also be a trigger so I can't do anything
about that about the adrenaline coming
down hydration is still important yes
but that's not the critical element what
else I also cut out I also cut out in my
drink and my in the car and my Camelback
I changed to just water because I
realized that my my like hydration drink
mix that I was using has fake sugars in
it I mean almost everything does like
that that's Aminta so I was like oh my
gosh like that stuff causes headaches so
you know maybe it causes migraines too
so so I cut that out and shifted to just
water and so I ten I did a little bit
better at the end so but since you have
since you stopped racing do you still
get them from time to time or no it's
only it was only always like the day
after racing um it was usually but I've
had them outside of that too yeah I had
one the last one I had was yeah it was
kind of as like late November was after
the season but it was it lasted about
two days it never got to being nauseous
but man I was like two three days yeah
it's so miserable people that I used to
I mean I'm I'm kind of one of those suck
it up buttercup kind of people like get
on with it and you're
just take a Tylenol or take a excedrin
or take a whatever and drink some water
and just stop complaining but yeah until
you've had one you really don't know how
bad they are they're pretty debilitating
yeah I've never had one but I just see
how much Juli suffers and I just I can't
we can't do anything I couldn't even
sleep mhm
s and that's the real problem is that he
it would wake me up because my head hurt
so bad is brutal yeah so but you haven't
found the ultimate to make cure yet but
um maybe just it'll be something that
just fades away over time and yeah I
hope so yeah I hope that your Wi-Fi
figures it out too because they're
they're uh they're no fun no all right
well we got to wrap this up here but I
want to I want to UM take us out with
maybe some you know words of inspiration
or encouragement to you know somebody
who's listening to this who's you know
inspired by your story your example is
looking for a lifestyle change and just
needs you know that spark to get them
off the couch and and begin well the
journey is really about the journey
actually my word of the year last year
in 2017 was truth and the journey is to
find your truth and to really know who
you are there's so much strength in that
and so the book is scratching the
surface on especially at the beginning
on the getting to that point I mean
there's even a chapter about mantras and
there's like a magic marker mantra
section where you can kind of help
develop your own with keywords that are
triggers for you that feel good and
resonate with you so but it's really
about having a healthy association with
food and exercise in a way that's going
to help you be better because food is
medicine and exercise is incredibly
productive for not only if your body
physically and your agility and your
flexibility and your ability to be able
to maneuver throughout your life into
old age but also from a hormonal
standpoint and from a confidence
standpoint and just the you know when
people people look at 100 pushups so
like I can't do 100 pushups and I'm like
yeah no kidding I can't do 100 straight
either but I do 10 sets to 10
and I I'm not takes me a few minutes but
I get through it and you know some
people takes more but it's all doable so
there's a level of confidence that comes
through that and so when we're at peace
of ourselves and confident in ourselves
and feel good and I'm not dragged down
by food that isn't real I mean if the
food if your food isn't made by the Sun
or a byproduct of the Sun then it's not
really food so it's about getting to
real food and taking care of yourself so
I love seeing people coming to their own
with a level of confidence and it's not
again it if your goal is to lose weight
what are you gonna do when the three
months is over stop I hope that you're I
hope most people do they well I hope
that with this book if they do read it
and they do the program your life will
change but for the best and that you
won't ever turn back and you'll be
waiting for hopefully the next pretty
intense book to come out awesome I love
it Danica Patrick you're an inspiration
the book is pretty intense awesome
everybody should pick it up I appreciate
you coming to talk to me thank you it's
great that's like not choppin here on
the daily so what else do you have going
on here in LA well let's see yeah we
went to Joe Rogan got one more podcast
and then maybe see some friends that I
haven't seen in a while oh I'm shooting
doing a warrior photo shoot so I'm like
fully like doing this all on my own to
develop like a really really great
website to create some branding around
warrior at this point in time for the
last year it's really just been on HSN
and it's been just like basic basic
shots with the clothes on their website
but you know some of my friends are like
where do I get it and there's some stuff
that's not all available there and you
know I want to help develop it I want it
to be my baby and and done in the way
that I want and so I really want I
really going there with the branding so
hired models yeah I hired the stylist
hired the photographer in fact the
photographer for the cover of my book
and all the lifestyle photos in it is
shooting warrior tomorrow so
so I'm really excited to see him his
name's Scott and and so yeah it's a full
production shoot and gosh I don't know
whatever else whatever else pops up a
little life and flow you know becoming
this crazy entrepreneur lifestyle
entrepreneur and I love it it's fun it's
really just flowing through things and
their passion projects and when we do
things that we're passionate about it
resonates with people they can tell you
know they curse they know if it's real
yeah and then when you go do an
interview actually know what the heck
you're talking about because I did it
you know I mean the worst thing is is
when you do something and you have to
talk about it and you really don't have
content because it wasn't your thing
where there's nothing in my life that I
do that I don't understand to a very
high level I mean okay do I understand
every last detail about winemaking no
but I understand of quite a bit about it
so do I ever understand every element -
how close are manufactured in the
process no but I'm like constantly
working on it and you know making that
all better for myself and for the
consumer so you know I am I'm very very
involved with everything I do and the
the most involved thing that I've done
over the last two years has been this
book and I do call it my worst paying
job because of how much time I put into
it but it was by all means my most
fulfilling job as well even if all I did
was change my mom's life yeah that's
very cool yeah awesome so thank you
you're welcome thank you very much if
people want to connect with you
afghani cap a track pretty much Saamy
my.com warriors coming a website know
what that's what the photos for but you
out you have like Instagram account set
up for all of those - right yeah yep
there's Instagram accounts yep so we try
and get the information out there all
right thanks so much thank you peace
[Music]